- [Host] They create worlds from thin air.
They tell stories in silence.
I'm talking, of course, about mimes.
And the many considered
the most famous mime
in history was not only a
world-renowned performer,
but also saved children from
the Nazis during World War II.
That man was Marcel Marceau.
- [Shawn] Marcel Marceau is probably
the most iconic image of mime.
- [Host] And that's Shawn Wen.
- [Shawn] Hi.
- [Host] She's the author
of "A Twenty Minute Silence
Followed by Applause," a
book about Marceau's life.
- [Shawn] The way that we picture a mime
is someone who performs without speaking,
and a lot of this has to
do with Marcel Marceau.
He really influenced a
lot of our visual culture.
Michael Jackson's moonwalk is modeled
after his walking against the wind.
He performed up until his death in 2007,
and he toured the world
over and over again.
- [Host] Before his legacy as a mime,
Marceau was a young boy in France.
It was here he would find
his hero in the movies.
- [Shawn] His inspiration
was Charlie Chaplin,
his humor, his use of physicality.
Even from a young age,
Mareau displayed this
kind of like uncanny physical gift.
- [Host] However, in May
of 1940, Marceau's life
would change forever.
- [Shawn] Marceau was 16 years old
when Germany marched on
France and his childhood
ended all at once.
Marceau's father died in Auschwitz,
and both he and his brother
were very much involved
in the war effort against the Nazis.
- [Host] And it was Marceau's skills
as a performer that
made him a unique asset.
- [Shawn] There's a story
about Marcel Marceau
saving a group of children
from an orphanage.
He dressed them up as campers,
and he would walk them
into safety in Switzerland.
He was doing mimicry, and he was acting,
and, essentially, he was entertaining them
to the point where they could pretend
as if they were going on vacation,
rather than fleeing for their lives.
Another story was that he was encountering
a large group of 30 German soldiers.
And in that moment, he
pretended that he was actually
at the front of a large
group of French soldiers,
and they actually surrendered to him.
It seems as if this
natural knack for acting
ended up becoming a
part of his involvement
in the war effort.
It's been described that
he wasn't just miming
because he loved mime.
During the war he was miming for his life.
- [Host] In many ways,
Marceau's wartime experience
would shape his life's work.
- [Shawn] He spent his
life circling the world
over and over again, telling these stories
through his body in a
way that defied language.
There's something about that
that almost seems like an effort
to bring the world back together
doing something that anyone,
regardless of language
or nationality, can understand
just by looking at him.
(serious music)